hi I'm Will Ferrell  this sucks hold on just a second what  what's wrong Ryan do you have any idea  what it's like to be in a Will Ferrell  Christmas movie that's not awful yes I  was there when we shot it I don't think  they're expecting elf yes they are  instead they're getting a musical from  two guys with questionable pitch hey hey  hey  sorry  it's okay this is easy some simple  disclaimers hey everyone spirited is not  elf it's not Deadpool either it is a  musical it is funny anything else it's  on Apple TV plus where the hell is that  foreign  [Music]  will and I are so excited for you to see  our movie musical spirited now we want  to dispel the rumors that we didn't do  all the singing ourselves this is 100  pure Ryan and will here  hold on a second  sorry Ryan it's been a long time since  I've done this  I thought you sounded great Ryan thank  you will  nailed it